>> Testing testing testing,
this is a captioning test.
Testing testing testing.
Testing testing 123.  Testing
testing 123.
>> Good afternoon or evening,
depending on what you prefer.
Good evening guests and
colleague colleagues, I would
like to extend a warm welcome to
all of you.  Thank you for
joining the library of congress
and the library this evening for
the 2017 Frederic  R and Molly
S.
Kellogg lecture on
juris prudence.
>> I apologize if I have
massacres any names.  Thank you
Mr. And Mrs. Kellogg for your
support and for joining us this
evening, we really appreciate
your support.
(Applause). .  Thanks to you,
the library has the pleasure of
welcoming these legal scholars
to debate a variety of
interesting and legal
philosophical topics.  This year
is no exception.  We are
delighted that professor Jeremy
Waldron of New York University
school of law joins us this
evening to address how countries
regulate immigration,
specifically if nations have a
right to consider their economic
and cultural
interests to
-- for the 2017
Frederic  R. And Molly Kellogg
lecture on jurisprudence.
>> Greetings.
This is the fifth biannual
lecture, we have reached our
eighth anniversary.  Ronald
Dworkin was the first, and
Joseph Roz in March 2011,
Michael Sandel in 2015.  Today,
we are pleased to have professor
Jeremy Waldron of New York
University.  Before introducing
him, who we first met in England
in 2000, I would like to thank
the jury that chose him without
knowing that fact.
Mark Metish, Don Wallace, and
the library of congress.  Molly
and I are insulated
from the selection
process.
She served Representative Pickle
of Austin, Texas, who if still
actival,
actival,ative was the first to
get things back on thethe
partisan
tract.
Our goal is more modest.
But here also, it is to give
time and incentive to legal
scholars to think through the
major philosophical issues of
our time and of the law.
Endowed lectures can influence
the law, the lectures at Yale,
and the lectures at Harvard
battled back and forth, like
heavyweight
crews.  There was the lecture
in 1958, challenging the
use
of the
constitution
.
And our lecture, positivism, and
the separation of law and
morals, and Dworkin's
eply,
reply.
They had given lectures at
Harvard and Yale, and addressed
issues
through a command of
fundamental theory, equality,
dignity, torture, hate speech,
judicial review, positiveism
and, not least, legislation,
which might be at the heart of
his theoretical program.
Last week, I was in Cambridge
for the bicentennial of Harvard
Law School, attended by six
justices, including the chief,
with a day of seminars, where
much was said about legal
education at Harvard, but not a
word about hand, heart, Dworkin
positiveism, principles, the
great issues of
the last century.
These topics are virtually
dead at Harvard today.  He
teaches a course on legislation,
so I ask, do you cover
Jeremy Waldron? Legal
positiveism claims that it must
be considered from it's sources,
the least of which is
democratic legislation.  But the
theorists have failed to take
that dispute of positiveism to
its crucial next point: How can
and should a view of legislation
address the philosophical
issues of the last
century?
That had been professor
Waldron's question.  This
questioning is typical of
Jeremy, who takes his
questioning back to John lockke,
who feels deeply about our
country, pursues topics in
detail, focusing like a
microscope without losing the
big picture.
Yes, he does cover Waldron, so
there is hope for Harvard.  I
give you professor Jeremy
Waldron, and after, you are all
invited to the reception in the
Madison Hall on the first floor.
(Applause).
Aauso
>> Thank you, the topic is
immigration, which is a pressing
issue for people who were
former green card holders, like
me.
I want to say -- (speaker far
from mic) -- a little bit about
the relationship
between the two.
Jurisprudence is the study of
law and legal reasoning, and the
study of law in the abstract
sense.
It is special, and in especially
special ways.  It is special
because it embodies the first
principles of the law in a
family of legal systems, like
the juris prudence of the common
law, or Islamic law, or it is
special because it studies the
principles of a topic, like
criminal law, or the law of
torts, or law of immigration.
We will look at the laws that
allow, permit, and restrict
human movement on the face of
the earth, the movement from
society to society, nation to
nation.
The inquiry is analogous to
other forms of special
jurisprons,
ce,
and we
try to go to a better
perspective of law.
A foundational approach is
different from what my
philosophical colleagues call an
applied ethics approach.  In
applied ethics, someone sets out
a policy problem as it exists,
and it considers evaluations in
favor of, or against, particular
aspects of that policy problem
as it is presented in the
politics of
country.
Instead of doing applied ethics
of immigration, which is an
honorable enterprise, I want to
take us
deeper.